bienvenidos de nuevo ojalá hayan tenido
un poco de intuición de lo que es el
rotacional de un campo vectorial porque
ahora vamos a calcularlo y si tu único
objetivo es aprobar un examen y no
entender la naturaleza del universo lo
cual yo creo que sería muy triste pero
aunque esa sea tu intención de cualquier
forma hay que saber calcularlo aunque
sería mucho más divertido cuando tienes
la inclusión entonces posiblemente nunca
olvidarás de qué se trata
tomemos el rotacional de un campo
vectorial uno que cuesta visualizar pero
que podemos entender por las matemáticas
así que digamos que el campo vectorial y
vamos a hacerlo en tres dimensiones para
hacer un ejemplo más complicado digamos
vamos a intentarlo de forma improvisada
no sé en la dirección x digamos que es x
x cuadrada porque por el seno de z esto
en la dirección x es decir multiplicando
por el vector y muy bien y ahora le
sumamos no sé ojalá pudiera escuchar sus
comentarios sugerencias para que poner
digamos que ponemos xy cuadrado
por z en la dirección de multiplican do
al vector j y ahora en la dirección zeta
pongamos cosa de x 12 9 y sale esto en
la dirección z ahora
digamos que podemos ver el rotacional de
este campo vectorial
que por cierto lo escribo como cold
porque esa es su expresión en inglés ok
pero estamos hablando del rotacional
entonces digamos que este rotacional
podemos verlo como un producto cruz o un
producto vectorial del operador nabla
que es el triangulito invertido y el
campo vectorial ahora cuando usamos esta
anotación que tenemos un vector
descompuesto en sus componentes x jay-z
o si es hijo take a pues tomamos un
determinante verdad de cierta matriz
ahorita vamos a mostrar cómo entender el
producto cruz entonces qué es lo que
hacemos el producto cruz será igual a
déjenme déjenme poner la anotación está
del determinante bueno no tenía que
poner una línea derechita pero no
importa como tomamos el producto cruz
pues tomamos los vectores unitarios y
los escribimos en el primer renglón
verdad tenemos el vector y j
y ahora en el siguiente renglón lo que
vamos a poner son las componentes de
nuestro operador nabla muy bien que en
este caso si recuerdan tiene como
componentes y decimos ponerlo con otro
color el operador no habla tiene como
componentes la parcial respecto de x
luego la parcial respecto de iu y
finalmente la parcial respecto de z
correcto déjenme reescribir el operador
nabla esto lo ponemos como parcial
respecto de x en la dirección y más la
parcial respecto de y en la dirección j
más la parcial respecto de z en la
dirección acá entonces los componentes
son en x jay-z son estas derivadas
parciales verdad ahora en el último
renglón lo que vamos a poner son las
componentes del campo vectorial
posiblemente me quedaré sin espacio pero
bueno en la primera sería equis cuadrada
y 69 z tengo que apretar un poquito más
para que quepa después va xy cuadrada
zeta
y finalmente vamos a escribir coseno de
x coseno de g
perfecto ahora esos son los componentes
x jay-z de nuestro campo y ya finalmente
estamos listos para tomar el
determinante verdad bueno posiblemente
saldrá muy confuso y engorroso pero
vamos a tratar entonces esto va a ser
igual a la unidad vectorial y déjenme
usar otro color
y este este vector lo vamos a
multiplicar por este sub determinante al
tachar su columna y su renglón que ocupa
y nos queda una matriz verdad del cual
calculamos su determinante pero en
realidad cuando multiplicamos
estamos hablando de aplicar el operador
sobre la función correspondiente verdad
entonces la primera vamos a tomar la
parcial respecto de y de la expresión
coseno de x coseno de y como si
estuviéramos tomando el determinante de
esta sub matriz y ahora hay que restar
la parcial respecto de zeta de x ye
cuadrada c está muy bien
ahora qué ocurre con nuestra componente
j entonces ponemos más j por cuales
quitamos su renglón y su columna de jota
y hacemos el determinante de la matriz
que nos queda verdad entonces esta es la
parcial respecto de x de coseno de x
coseno de y muy bien y luego le restamos
la le restamos déjenme ponerlo a acá de
este lado la parcial respecto de zeta
no perdón x cuadrada y seno de set muy
bien y finalmente nuestra componente acá
y bueno en la componente k que es lo que
tenemos esperen perdón cuando tomamos el
determinante hay que recordar utilizamos
esto que es como como reglas no sé como
si fuera de burgo
bueno aquí ponemos un más y un menos y
un más verdad entonces este más que le
corresponde a la j en realidad era un
menos
disculpen disculpen el error esto es
sólo parte del algoritmo de cómo
calcular un determinante verdad así que
bueno finalmente teníamos nuestra
componente cada verdad ya esto lo
multiplicamos por el determinante que
resulta de quitar su columna y su
renglón así que nos queda la parcial
respecto de x
o más bien aplicado a equis y cuadrada z
verdad que es lo que resulta de quitar
los el renglón y la columna de del
vector acá y ahora restamos la parcial
respecto de y de quien de x cuadrada y
seno de zeta verdad otra vez porque
quitamos un renglón y una columna
entonces ponemos x cuadrada y seno de
zeta
muy bien ahora vamos a tratar de
simplificar la y pues no queda de otra
hay que quitar espacio sale y bueno me
parece que puedo borrar todo esto
degenere vamos a
todo ya no lo necesitamos no esto no era
lo que quería hacer lo quería poner como
negro
tenemos esto vamos a hacer un poco de
limpieza con permiso borra eso limpiamos
aquello ok ahora solo hay que
simplificarlo al calcular las derivadas
parciales verdad cuál es la derivada
parcial respecto de ella bueno como x es
una constante para estos fines entonces
vamos a ponerlo
este es nuestro vector y que multiplica
a la parcial respecto del de coseno de x
coseno de ella josé no de x es una
constante así que solamente sale y luego
cuál es la derivada respecto de ley de
coseno de y pues es menos seno de iu
verdad entonces vamos a poner el menos
de este lado
ahora
qué es lo que tenemos hay que restarle
vamos a restarle la derivada parcial
respecto de z de toda esta expresión
tops este olvide creo que seré el el
paréntesis antes de tiempo vamos a
reescribir lo entonces la parcial de
esto respecto de ya era coseno de x por
seno de iu y le poníamos el menos verdad
y ahora sí ahora sí la parcial respecto
de z de esto y luego lo restamos pues
qué es lo que nos queda xy cuadrada es
constante y al derivar z pues nos queda
uno solamente verdad así que restamos x
cuadrado y ahora sí todo esto multiplica
al vector y muy bien esa es nuestra
magnitud en la dirección y vamos a ver
quién es en la dirección j dar derivada
parcial respecto de x de esto pues ahora
quien es constante es coseno de y por lo
tanto nos queda menos seno de x por
coseno de g
y ahora hay que restarle la derivada
respecto de z de x cuadrada y seno de
zeta verdad
otra vez x cuadrada y es una constante
por lo tanto solo derivamos seno de zeta
y nos queda x cuadrada y coseno de zeta
que es la derivada de seno de set y esta
es la magnitud en la dirección j ya casi
acabamos ahora sólo nos falta calcular
la derivada parcial de xd xd cuadrada
zeta que simplemente es cuadrada zeta y
restamos la derivada parcial respecto de
y de esta expresión de acá abajo lo
demás es una constante así que nos queda
x cuadrada seno de zeta y esto
multiplica al vector cada verdad porque
es la magnitud que tenemos en la
dirección k y ya terminamos es decir
digo todavía podríamos simplificar un
poco y agrupar y hacerlo esto más limpio
pero esencialmente ya lo hemos hecho ya
ya terminamos de calcular el rotacional
entonces digo podríamos quitar signos y
demás como aquí verdad que puse en
amarillo pero bueno lo importante es que
esto es el rotacional de un campo
vectorial en cualquier punto x jay-z es
decir hemos tomado el producto cruz del
operador nabla y el campo vectorial yo
obtuvimos algo bastante peludo verdades
dadas de espantoso estos pero después
vamos a repasar este algoritmo vamos a
generar más intuición para que quede
todo esto más claro nos vemos en el
próximo vídeo